[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau journal de la rédaction nous
sommes le 18 octobre voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer au cours du prochain quart
d'heure à la mission locale présentait
aujourd'hui son nouveau dispositif pour
aider les plus jeunes à trouver un
emploi la garantie jeunes profitent
depuis début octobre à une quinzaine de
personnes sur l'agglomération le
mouvement en marche lancée par emmanuel
mâcon se structure dans les yvelines une
réunion vient de se tenir à versailles
et puis le petit moulin des vaux de
cernay a entamé une seconde vie c'est
aujourd'hui un musée qui parle de
paysages d'histoire et de patrimoine
'l'annonce a donc été faite hier psa
prévoirait de supprimer plus de 2000
emplois en france selon le syndicat cgt
du groupe au total 2000 133 postes
supprimés mais pas de licenciement la
direction miserait sur les départs en
pré-retraite et les départs volontaires
une centaine de personnes partir est
aussi en le congé longue durée l' usine
de poissy pourraient être parmi les plus
impactés avec cette décision 250 postes
en moins l'année prochaine une annonce
néanmoins démenti par la direction du
groupe nous avons contacté le délégué
cgt du groupe psa peugeot citroën jean
pierre merci à écouter
justement éviter ces suppressions de
postes mais faire faire que les deux
villes de 2 milliards 2,4 milliards de
bénéfices servent à maintenir l'emploi
dans toutes les usines en france
c'est-à-dire embaucher les intérimaires
et les chômeurs en cdi pour compenser
tous les départs en pré retraite et tous
les départs volontaires bien évidemment
la cgt est pour les départs en pré
retraite le plus tôt possible d'ailleurs
on est pour que les anciens laisse la
place
qu'ils méritent leur pré retraite et qui
laisse la place aux jeunes chômeurs il
est vraiment nécessaire et vitale pour
le site de poitiers d'embauché en cdi
les intérimaires et puis les épis d
épilepsie les chauffeurs qui ne
demandent qu'à travailler
propos recueillis par camille lambert à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aujourd'hui la
mission locale a présenté son nous
dispositifs pour aider les plus jeunes à
trouver un emploi
la garantie jeunes c'est son nom elle
profite déjà depuis le début du mois
d'octobre une quinzaine de personnes sur
l'agglomération un accompagnement
intensif visites d'entreprises et
ateliers thématiques qui doivent
permettre au bout d'un nom à l'insertion
dans la vie professionnelle le reportage
de nicolas kirillovitch
leur objectif est clair trouver un
emploi ils sont une quinzaine de saint
quentinois a bénéficié de la nouvelle
garantie jeunes dispositif mis en place
par la mission locale et qui a pour
objectif de favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle
atelier numéric découverte de
l'entreprise ou encore aide à la
recherche d'emploi les jeunes sont
soumis à un programme intensif comme à
nice à 20 ans qui a stoppé ses études en
deuxième année de bac pro on a plusieurs
ateliers et à des ateliers
d'amélioration de cv
il ya des aides on est sorti sur paris
pour une journée d'intégration on est
allé voir le musée du louvre on a été
sur un bateau-mouche le fait en fait
d'être boostée par deux animatrices qui
est sienne ce dispositif nous motiver à
fond avec elle et ça met de la bonne
humeur depuis début octobre les
bénéficiaires de la garantie jeunes sont
suivis par la mission locale et s'ils
sont seulement une quinzaine à en
profiter actuellement le dispositif
devrait monter en puissance
progressivement 40 ils viennent c'est
vraiment un dispositif totalement
nouveau ça renouvelle nos pratiques
professionnelles et on voulait pas
s'engager sur plus de jeunes on veut là
à voir un retour d'expérience au bout de
six mois dans pour éventuellement monter
en puissance c'est possible en tout 150
personnes devraient bénéficier de la
garantie jeunes sur l'ensemble de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'ils sont
assidus et investi ces derniers se
verront verser une allocation mensuelle
de 460 euros
dans l'actualité également cette réunion
qui s'est tenue vendredi dernier en
préfecture des yvelines en présence du
préfet et des élus du département le
préfet et qui a rappelé qu'aucune
décision n'avait été prise sur l'accueil
des migrants pour les sites envisagés
mais que la création de 300 à 350 places
supplémentaires devraient être
effectives dès le début du mois de
novembre avec une juste répartition il a
conclu en précisant que les réquisitions
n'était cependant pas exclues en cas
d'urgence
politique à présent avec le mouvement en
marche lancée par emmanuel macron qui
fait des émules dans le département des
yvelines les militants se sont réunis le
week-end dernier à versailles à la
royale factory ils ont évoqué les
dernières propositions de l'ancien
ministre qu'ils aimeraient bien
aujourd'hui voir se déclarer
officiellement candidat images patrick
jacques de dixmude et commentaires
nicolas landry
plus de deux mille personnes seraient en
marche derrière emmanuel macron dans le
département des yvelines le mouvement a
organisé ce samedi 15 octobre à
versailles une réunion publique objectif
faire une restitution partielle des deux
premiers meetings de l'ancien ministre
de l'économie pour présenter le
diagnostic de la grande marche cette
initiative qui a permis d'aller
rencontrer les français
reparler tu peux des thèmes qu'emmanuel
a lancé les pistes de réflexion et sur
lesquels aujourd'hui nos compatriotes
yvelinois vont nous donner leur avis
director cette grande marche a mis en
évidence deux thèmes prioritaires pour
les français leur vie quotidienne et
leur engagement
ben moi ce que j'aime bien c'est un il
fait appel à l'intelligence des monts
intelligent rire des gens et français et
puis de il compte beaucoup sur
l'implication des citoyens initialement
je suis pas mieux pour m'accrocher lui
parce que c'était un mouvement qui enfin
à les écouter les français plutôt que de
réfléchir tout seul et puis ensuite de
proposer des choses et j'espère vraiment
qu'il va se présenter parce qu'il a il a
une puissance une intelligence est
quelqu'un qui s'est énormément travaillé
reste une question d'envergure emmanuel
macron sera-t-il candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 la candidature
elle est secondaire ce qui compte c est
ce que le projet que nous allons
construire il sera en phase ou pas avec
le pays et pour le construire nous
souhaitons faire avec les gens donc
prendre le temps de le faire l'ancien
conseiller économique de françois
hollande tient ce mardi 18 octobre son
dernier meeting à montpellier il
proposera ensuite ses solutions
le salon international de l'alimentaire
se tient en ce moment à villepinte et il
accueille plusieurs sociétés des
yvelines l'une d'entre elles mêmes bases
et sur le secteur de trappes à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son nom albert
elle c'est un glacier artisanale fondée
en 2000 une société qui a été reprise
cette année par un jeune entrepreneur
avec son épouse le reportage sur place à
villepinte lors de ce salon avec
anne-laure l'anguille
avec cette huile exposants et une
centaine de pays représentés le salon
international de l'alimentaire est un
rendez vous incontournable pour les
entreprises du secteur pierre mainini
dirigeants d'al père elle est installé
son stand ça nous permet d'identifier
des possibilités pour l'export notamment
sur le ciel on a fait des jolies contact
notamment sur l'asie qui assez friands
des des produits français tisanes aux
halles père elle réalise un chiffre
d'affaires de 650 mille euros dont 10 %
à l'export une société aux ambitions
internationales mais bien ancrée dans
les yvelines son positionnement à
trappes lui offre plusieurs avantages
pour s'ouvrir sur la normandie est donc
toute la logistique export avec le port
du havre mais également pouvoir fournir
assez rapidement les restaurants les
épiceries fines à paris spécificité de
ce glacier sa production est 100%
artisanale est naturelle en 2017 tout le
lait servant à fabriquer ses produits
proviendra des laiteries de grignon
pierre mainini et son équipe l'est aussi
libre champ à leur créativité et
confectionne des parfums originaux leurs
ambitions dans cinq ans toujours bien
ancrée en ile de france
plus reconnu qu'on ne l'est aujourd'hui
est reconnu comme un acteur régional
important et puis avec une petite
notoriété à l'export
enquêter avec nicolas mottin pour
retrouver le mystérieux gueule d'ange un
poilu de la première guerre mondiale
voici le point de départ de ce jeu
proposé en ligne sur internet par le
conseil départemental c'est un moyen de
découvrir l histoire autrement les
précisions de maxime le mène avec ce
reportage réalisé pour le département
justement
quel poids lui se cache derrière le
pseudonyme gueule d'ange ces collégiens
mène l'enquêté au travers d'un jeu en
ligne dans lequel ils doivent résoudre
des énigmes au fil de leurs
investigations ils apprennent à
exploiter des documents d'archivés et
aux fiches militaires des photos et
journal
tous ces documents viennent des archives
départementales qui ont lancé le jeu en
2013 on voulait quelque chose qui soit à
la fois ludique et pédagogique des
archives qui sont animés le jeu est
entrecoupé de vidéos didactiques et
apparemment ça vaut le coup d'aller
jusqu'au bout c'est hyper surprenant
s'attend pas du tout à cet angle
la grande guerre est au programme de la
classe de 3e pour ce professeur gueule
d'ange est un très bon support
pédagogique
c'est un jeu qui permet vraiment de
rendre l'histoire réelle pour les élèves
qui va les interpeller qui peut les
mettre aussi en recherche de
d'information dans leur propre famille
karl enquêtes se déroulent dans les
yvelines l'arrière grand père de paul
habitait à quelques pas de l'église de
conflans comme l'un des personnages du
scénario en voyant cette cinématique
paul a eu un déclic et décidé d'en
apprendre un peu plus sur son ancêtre
qui faisait de la prise de vue aérienne
pendant la guerre mon grand père avait
gardé des photos et un jour je suis allé
loin et il m'a sortir un carton avec
beaucoup de photos d'eux
on a un parc avait pris pour voir à peu
près où se situent les adversaires et
les alliés collégiens ou non tout le
monde peut participer râle enquête noter
qu'un concours est organisé chaque année
avec de nombreux lots numérique a gagné
petites techniques pour augmenter vos
chances jouer en équipe on peut
s'entraider si on n'arrive pas sur
certaines énigmes et ça permet de
cumuler nos points pour pouvoir
peut-être gagner à la fin et maintenant
à vous de jouer
et puisque l'on parle histoire également
lorànt deutsch ne donnera finalement pas
de représentation à la merise attrape
une intervention prévue dans le cadre du
salon histoire de lire à versailles et
qui devait se faire devant des
collégiens deux enseignants de cette
commune de trappes ont refusé d'être
associés à l'opération qu'il juge allait
à l'encontre de leur métier l'histoire
n'a pas pour but de faire aimer la
france selon eux réponse de l'écrivain
également comédien ces enseignants se
servent de l'histoire plutôt que de la
servir c'est une sorte de renaissance le
petit moulin des vaux de cernay a entamé
une deuxième vie la structure était
rachetée en 2012 par le département des
yvelines il a été confiée au parc
naturel de la naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse autrefois
accueille des peintres il en a reçu près
de 700 le petit moulin est aujourd'hui
un musée où on parle paysage histoire et
patrimoine visites guidées avec mélanie
poker
ou départementale 91 lieu-dit la vallée
dans le parc naturel de la haute vallée
de chevreuse le petit moulin est là
depuis 800 ans
d'abord moulin à farine il se transforme
en auberge depuis à peu près 150 ans on
a un phénomène de parisiens qui viennent
se ressourcer
attiré par ce concentré de nature et
il ya donc une époque où part par la
fameuse ligne de train la nuit de sault
et
les parisiens arrivés
à vous les trous et ensuite à s'arrimer
les chevreuse et été amenés en divisant
ce qu'on appelait pas tâche ô
au coeur des vaux de cernay ouvert au
public à la fin du mois d'août le moulin
appartient aujourd'hui au parc naturel
une exposition retrace son histoire
géologique mais aussi artistique de 1830
à 1870 s'il devient une colonie de
peintres paysagistes
c'est la première fois qu'il n'est pas
un paysagiste
de cernay
se retrouvent réunis dans un seul lieu
donc leurs tableaux sont dispersés dans
plusieurs musées de france même à
l'étranger on pour près de 700 plaintes
sont passés par les votes cerner
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle
avec des objets d'époque ou encore un
tutoriel ludique sur la création d'une
toile paysagère le petit moule invite à
la balade artistique ou patrimonial
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochaine édition mercredi
à 18h en direct pour la première
diffusion en attendant les programmes se
poursuivre sur notre antenne
[Musique]